there were so many bloopers and gags
produced in the office that they could
almost make up their own show some of
those cut gags were even funnier than
the final version of the scene here are
the best of those character-breaking
line fumbling moments now that he's
broken up with jan michael is pitifully
lonely and desperate enough to become
borderline obsessed with a model in an
office supply catalog desperate for
companionship before he gets too old and
can't have kids michael demands his
subordinates each write down the name of
a single woman they know that he can go
on a date with in the original scene
after a whole afternoon of michael's
self-pitying antics pam relents and says
she has someone for him her poor
unsuspecting landlady michael
uh
are you michael scott the blooper during
the scene came in the form of a poorly
delivered line
is she hot that was such a bad day
ryan howard introduced to us in the
pilot episode as a mild-mannered temp
has risen to the rank of corporate vp by
the beginning of season four when he
reintroduces himself to his favorite
branch in scranton neither is five
o'clock shadow nor his bluetooth nor his
new expensive suit succeed in getting
anyone to respect him the way he wants
the people who don't like him continue
not liking him and the people who do
won't stop treating him like he's still
the adorable little office temp that
everybody likes to pick on in the
original scene ryan snaps and admonishes
michael in front of the office i am your
boss now you're going to have to treat
me the same way you treated jan in the
bloopers steve carell and brian
bumgarner imitated him and he began
laughing
but
[Laughter]
after he finished laughing bj apologized
i'm really sorry i broke that was too
good this episode begins with a
despondent phyllis telling her
co-workers that she was flashed by a man
in a trench coat after she stopped to
help him with directions in the parking
lot michael goes back and forth between
making crass inappropriate jokes and
trying to host a series of women's
appreciation seminars and events for
which as jim points out he is completely
unqualified to manage i
would like to apologize
for all the men who thought this was a
laughing matter meanwhile dwight
announces the creation of a very serious
indeed anti-flashing task force that
will be run entirely by him even though
he has no clue how to investigate a
crime and local police are already on
the job while explaining the task force
to his co-workers he refers to phyllis
as phallus before apologizing phyllis
sorry
i've got penises on the brain
back to work everybody naturally a scene
like this would be hard to get through
with a straight face the cast tried it
multiple times breaking constantly at
one point rayne wilson who played dwight
tried to muscle through and complete the
scene
that is a risk that we have to no no no
i know what you're saying why don't you
keep going
with michael and pam out giving sales
training presentations to the other
regional branches jim and dwight are in
charge of the office things immediately
take a turn for the worse when they
realize they've forgotten kelly's
birthday kelly is angry and when dwight
stands up for gym she grows even angrier
hey
guys
jim tries to salvage the situation
before dwight yells back and makes it
worse by promising her a cake and a
party that afternoon it's probably not
that surprising that a scene like this
might have been a little too much fun to
shoot in other takes every time john
krasinski steps in to lower the
temperature rayne wilson shoots him a
shocked wild-eyed look hey guys
stop doing it
by the third failure they're all a
little bit frustrated but still having
plenty of fun
at the beginning of the fifth season the
scranton branch participates in a
company-wide weight loss competition
naturally things go astray kelly starves
herself and tries to buy a tapeworm from
creed dwight after insulting several of
his co-workers for their weight tricks
fill us into going on a non-existent
sales call only to abandon her forcing
her to burn calories on her walk back
there was no client dwight drove me to
an abandoned warehouse five miles away
and pushed me out of the car holly sets
up an hr meeting to address the madness
but michael ruins it by donning a
semi-deflated sumo suit and appearing in
character as michael clump an insulting
celebration of overweight people this
big fat pig is beautiful
the original scene is an office classic
but the gag version is even better well
hello everybody
karel had to try multiple takes before
everyone was able to hold in their
laughter
an excited andy and i'm not so excited
angela have decided at her insistence to
book shroot farms as their wedding venue
and are planning a lunch break trip to
check it out problem is proprietor
dwight doesn't know how to give
acceptable directions walk until you
hear the beehive when andy brings us up
dwight insists the directions are
perfectly normal how could it be more
clear
in the bloopers from the scene nobody
can keep a straight face as ed helms
tries out some bizarre obviously ad-lib
lines if you are
attacked by territorial crows
it clearly took quite a few tries to get
a usable take pam is pregnant with her
and jim's first child but she's
resisting everyone's attempts to get her
to the hospital if you ask her she'd say
she wants to wait until after midnight
for insurance purposes but the reality
is that she's scared of going into labor
and wants to drag it out jim is slowly
losing and trying to get her to the
hospital and at one point relies on
michael to tell him when her
contractions start coming every five
minutes when he finds out they're now
coming every two minutes he yells at
michael for not informing him earlier we
waited too long two minutes doesn't do
us any good well what happened to porn
okay jim in other takes the actors
struggle to make it through the scene
without cracking no what hold it
together
[Laughter]
the kick off to season four is meredith
ending up hospitalized after michael
hits her with his car in the parking lot
she has a minor pelvic fracture and gets
a rabies shot after the doctor finds out
she might have been bitten by a bat when
one was trapped in the office during the
previous season this promised a
guilt-stricken michael to launch a fun
run race for the rabies cure despite the
fact that meredith likely doesn't have
rabies and as jim pointed out it's
already been cured while he's organizing
all that pam rallies the co-workers for
a lunch break carpool to visit meredith
in the hospital in a scene that didn't
make the final cut steve carell can't
get his line right when jenna fisher
tells everyone quotes okay we're leaving
for the hospital at one corel is
supposed to respond with quote like a
freedom tree instead he trips all over
the line okay so we're all leaving for
the hospital at one o'clock
free entry i can take three
[Laughter]
in season seven jim dwight and even
michael all seasoned and talented
salesmen lose a major potential client
to rival traveling rep danny cordray of
osprey paper michael promptly calls the
sales team to a brainstorming session
upon returning to the office and asks
everyone for ideas to outmaneuver
cordray stanley how do we combat him you
sell better okay michael mistake stanley
sarcasm for indifference tells him to
leave and suggests he has diabetes
stanley insists he doesn't have diabetes
and would like to stay for once as
cordray affected his paycheck but he
eventually leaves see i could tell by
the sound you made when you stood up
that you have okay yes phyllis that
scene took several tries to nail
initially when michael said his last
line to stanley every cast member in the
room lost it see just the noise you made
when you stood up
[Laughter]
one of the major storylines of season
three was the merging of the defunct
stamford connecticut branch with the one
in scranton martin one of the stanford
transplants is a former convict who'd
been briefly imprisoned for insider
trading long before starting his career
with dunder mifflin once he finds out
about this michael tries awkwardly
defending martin simply because he's
black and michael is worried about
stereotypes
but i just want to declare publicly that
i
trust him completely then when his
subordinates start inquiring about
prison and pretending to wish they were
in it michael sees martin as a threat to
office morale and his fun boss schtick
in one scene michael barges into the
break room where martin is casually
explaining his prison time to his new
co-workers but a lot of fun talk about
prison today but i am here to scare you
straight in the bloopers not knowing the
camera was rolling a crew member audibly
starts talking in the background forcing
everyone to reset for a new take we're
rolling melissa how are you i thought
somebody just said now in another take
steve carell is delivering lines in his
iconic purple bandana when the group
begins laughing
where did you pinch him
thunder mifflin infinity ryan howard's
new paper by an online portal that he
hopes will modernize the alien company
is going live to celebrate the office
decides to order some pizza for a branch
party michael comes out of his office to
announce that hot food is on the way
good news we get to go home in a
different take leslie david baker
doesn't just say that line he shouts it
joyously wide-eyed throwing his hands
into the air and leaning back in his
seat i have some good news we get to go
home this prompts steve carell followed
quickly by the entire cast to break into
uncontrollable laughter leslie himself
is laughing harder than anyone john
krasinski is howling so hard he holds
his hands over his face if you don't at
least crack up watching this you may be
dead inside
if you're watching a video about the
office you've almost certainly seen
what's arguably its greatest episode
season four's dinner party michael and
his borderline psychotic girlfriend and
former boss jan host an after work get
together at their condo with jim pam
andy angela dwight and dwight's former
babysitter whom he brought us a date the
episode in which michael and jan's
relationship unravels before the eyes of
their squirming guests over the course
of an evening filled with awkward house
tours failed business pitches games that
nobody likes a screaming match about
having kids passive-aggressive arguments
between the hosts a very late meal that
both pam and michael think jan is
poisoned and much more is a triumph of
cringe comedy that's never been matched
michael and jan seem to be playing their
own separate game and it's called let's
see how uncomfortable we can make our
guests the blooper reel is even more
entertaining the episode was famously
hard to shoot because everyone in it
simply could not stop laughing long
enough to get good takes in one take
steve carell talks about michael's tiny
plasma screen tv before saying quote
right over here jim to john krasinski i
guess what surround sound means is that
right over here jim
co-writer lee eisenberg said there's
nothing more satisfying than having
steve carell barely able to get through
his lines oh jesus
this is terrible
never finish this episode check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]